now last week call of duty vanguard was
announced for release on november 5th
and this weekend the playstation alpha
will be live with the champion hill mode
but now it's time to get the first ever
look at the campaign in action and to do
that we are joined by dave swenson from
sledgehammer games and laura bailey one
of the stars of the show and the winner
last year of best performance at the
game awards great to have you guys with
us we are so excited to get into the
real game play but first dave uh you
guys did call of duty uh world war ii a
couple years ago 2017 at sledgehammer
now you're going back to ww2 how is
vanguard different than what you did
before first of all i got to say it's
awesome to be here so thank you so much
thanks for calling and it's also like
it's super you know thrilling to be able
to represent the team behind vanguard so
vanguard is a totally new take on world
war ii uh world war ii is known for huge
epic battles on big battlefields uh and
and those happen not only in the western
front but also in the eastern front in
the pacific in north africa and in
vanguard you're going to be able to go
to all of those locations and play in
all those locations but for the team
something that was that resonated even
more with us were the real stories of
the real people who fought in world war
ii so these are diverse people from all
around the globe uh and and i don't know
there's there's something very inspiring
about these true stories now some of the
most interesting people that we
discovered in our research were those
men and women who were part of the
original special forces teams and so
call of duty vanguard is going to tell
their story tell the story of the birth
of special forces
well laura uh we saw last week the
reveal that you're going to be in this
game which is i know it's been a
lifelong dream of yours to be in a call
of duty
your character it ties into what dave's
talking about tell us about your
character paulina petrova yes i am
thrilled to be in my first call of duty
game uh it's crazy because there's not
you know a lot of
female roles in media about historical
war for obvious reasons and that's one
of the things that struck me about
paulina and when i started researching
for the role was
how many women were actually in the
soviet army in world war ii
there were tank operators and there were
fighter pilots and some of them like
polina were uh snipers
and so it's it's just really cool to get
to play a character that pays homage to
someone like
ludamila pavochenko who is and was one
of the deadliest snipers of all time wow
all right well i love that you guys take
you know take the reality but obviously
put the call of duty uh spin on it uh
let's talk a bit about what you guys are
going to show today i know you know
treyarch's working on zombies you guys
are working on an awesome campaign we
saw some multiplayer this weekend but
now we're going to do kind of a full a
level playthrough of a bunch of stuff in
the game what are we about to see here
today that's right so as i mentioned
earlier um the vanguard campaign is
telling the sport the story of the birth
of special forces and that leads right
into multiplayer on day one there's
going to be 20 maps so that people can
go in and play their their favorite
special forces operators one of which is
paulina petrova yeah and so uh what
we're going to show today which we're
really excited to show this is this is
gameplay this was captured in engine um
and we're gonna show uh paulina's story
now the the vanguard campaign starts
with with the team polina petrova and
her team on their first special forces
mission going into berlin right at the
end of the war um in april of 1945 but
this wasn't the start of the war for
polina polina started the war as a nurse
on the eastern front and so what we're
going to see
right now is is stalingrad we're going
to see paulina
in stalingrad and to view her experience
when song grad was invaded by the
germans
uh laura any set up here for what point
in in paulina's life or character arc
we're gonna see yeah i mean at the start
of the game you really see her as a
total badass you know she's
she's no nonsense nothing rattles her
and that's not an act she's she's seen
it all she's looked she's looked the
devil in the eye and said i'm coming for
you and in this level you really get to
see what what makes her become that way
you know she's
she's bright and almost innocent in her
outlook and uh
[ __ ] happens
all right well it's about to happen
right here guys thank you so much for
joining us we are now going to get this
extended look at call of duty vanguard
enjoy
now
uh
[Music]
oh
is
yes
[Music]
again
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[ __ ]
hey
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
up
uh
[Music]
yes
[Music]
uh
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
ah
can you tell me
[Music]
you're needed in the field
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
okay
[Music]
uh
hello
[Applause]
yes
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you